Gothenburg Sweden and I would be the
moderator and the interviewer at this
live broadcast where I will have the
privilege of interviewing 2,000 noble
from year 2000 Nobel laureate Eric
Carlson who was the one who first for
example
discovered the transmitter role of
dopamine in the brain and that will also
be the topic of today's discussion the
history of dopamine this educational web
seminar will be brought to you by a
company called lab roots which is a
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of scientific
virtual events such as this one they
have asked me to provide you with some
practical instructions before we start
which are the following this webcast is
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
title typing them in the Q&A box which
can be found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window we try to answer as
many questions as we can you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problem viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right
representation window or submit a
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar
server please click on the C button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits so with these
introductory words and instructions I
would like to say hello and welcome to
our Carlson who will today share his
view on dopamine both respect to
historical aspects and with respect to
current problems and prospects and hello
Eric nice to see you here
I thought we should start with a brief
history lesson and I think this would be
the appropriate place
to start this is late fifties this is
the testa and this guy is Vera Brody
could you please tell us about him when
I beat him I I was kind of astonished as
a matter of fact because I expected him
to be like the other professors academic
professors of my home University learn
Sweden and here I met another type of
person he described himself as a gambler
very little academic and he actually he
started out he he was actually born in
Liverpool but he as a child the family
when he was a child a family moved to
Canada and he went to school
and he started a career in boxing in a
successful career and for some reason
that I cannot go into details here he
made it took a made a decision to switch
into what into organic chemistry I think
he is the only person in the world
switched from boxing to organic
chemistry and from there he went he went
on into pharmacology and in pharmacology
he became a pioneer in a very special
modern at a time very modern kind of
pharmacology chemical pharmacology that
is that is pharmacology the rather than
traditionally by use you base yourself
on physiology now you brace yourself on
chemistry so you the important thing in
chemical Pharma quality to do chemical
analysis to know precisely find out well
where the dust occur Drago well as it is
fix itself what what kind of chemical
changes will there be so it it he his
his lab the lab of chemical pharmacology
at the National Institutes of Health was
in in I think on the absolute top of
Baba chemical pharmacology and I was
enormous ly successful to be able to be
accepted there as a visiting scientist
in 1955 and God what another thing very
very fortunate for me was that just a
few months before I came there they have
made a fundamental discovery and that
was that if you give a an anti-psychotic
drug called reserpine very much used in
those days and if you inject that into
an animal and then analyze for a
chemical in the brain that was one new
very little about but there were lots of
speculations about this chemical was
serotonin and if you inject reser pin
into an animal and analyze for serotonin
you will be just you believe you will be
astonished to find serotonin is gone
altogether and so that started out some
very interesting new research and I was
fortunate enough when I came there to
get a to go right into this research and
do some chemical analyses on serotonin
in blood platelets so that is how it
started do you think that Brody has been
sufficiently recognized should they ever
had the Nobel Prize will
the problem was that he was he opened up
an entirely new field and if you go to
the testament of noble it's very
specifically said that the prize should
be given for a specific discovery and
sometimes the committee they don't take
that's a serious three but sometimes
they do and in this case they did take
it seriously so he so he did get it but
he had his his his pupils and visiting
scientists like myself got prizes and
very very prestigious prizes and he got
lots of prizes himself but not the Nobel
Prize but number two of his his pupils
who be who got it I was one of them the
other one was was Axelrod genius
accident okay so and you just spent a
year so supposed okay and then you went
back to this building and this is not
Gothenburg this is not this is money
this is the the the place where the
Department of Pharmacology of the
University of lund was located in those
days now is useful very different
purposes so that's where I when I
started out to study medicine and I was
accepted there by the professor to to
become a
young scientists among nuances a Torah
scroll and I defy I did work classical
classical physiological pharmacological
work but also with a touch of chemistry
my professor was very he wanted me to go
into chemistry he actually guided me
into chemistry I must say so but but he
so I started out in a very different
field in dealing with bone metabolism
and usually using something brand new at
that time the radioactive isotopes
possibility to measure 20 quantitatively
so and my thesis then dealt with that
but then later on my professors told me
that maybe this calcium metabolism and
Barone isn't really in in in the core of
pharmacology maybe we should do
something else so and I thought I better
do what I said so I I got through some
very good friends of mine and they
helped me to get in touch with Brody's
Brody's lab so that is so but now after
having done those five months I came
back and this of course from now on I
was a serotonin man very much but not
quite serotonin because I got the idea
that maybe serotonin is not the only
thing you should look at there are some
closely related compounds in the brain
that all they are chemically related but
they are not in developes they are
catecholamines but they seem to have
functions that are similar and in the
periphery
these compounds were very important
adrenaline and noradrenaline so and I
thought maybe one should just just to
see does researching work on the
catecholamines so so that if you just
may interrupt here at this time was
certainly recognized as a brand new
transmitter the no I think that Brodie
probably he he thought of it in terms of
the day some kind of transmitter but but
in those days there was no evidence
really there was no evidence for that
matter that in the brain the
catecholamines
could be duro transmitters either okay
in the brain itself I could be in the
nerves around II not in the brain was
chemically new transmission in the brain
accepted at this time not even that it
was not accepted at all okay okay so so
I got started I I had learned something
very well first of all I was enormously
fortunate because the man in the whole
world who we would be the best one to
get to start to collaborate with was
Neils okay Hillard and where was he
located well at the University of
learned very very strange phenomenon and
this man he had done some very
fundamental work on the adrenal medulla
he had been able to localize that
organelle in the adrenal medulla where
adrenaline is stored he called the
granules it crosby's some of those
sometimes
for the vesicles and so he had done some
very fundamental work on that so he was
right in the middle of of research the
kind of research where I wanted to go
into and he had a methodology and
everything so I wrote to him already
when I was in the US and also would he
like to collaborate with me and he said
yes so as soon as I got home we started
more or less immediately to do work and
within a few months we had we had done
the experiment so we had given reserve
bid to rabbits and found that that the
adrenaline that he could analyze in the
other medela had gone wasn't very little
so it was there was a good start before
going further the background of all
these slides of course we wouldn't have
that without alert yes that was a little
later that we started out with this very
good technology but rather primitive
technology that was needed to do the
experiments of showing reserve in acting
on adrenaline
but as this work proceeded there was
became a need to really locate not only
in the adrenal medulla but also in in
the in the peripheral nerves in the
brain to locate these amines and he he
did what you see the green color is the
result of a chemical reaction that Hill
up and his colleagues invented that
could visualize in the fluorescence
microscope the abies serotonin
noradrenaline adrenaline could be could
be visualized in the in Indy electron
Mike I'm sorry in the fluorescence I was
later on also it in the
but the fluorescence microscope so that
was a was a very adult romantic step
forward so that's why we have this
background yeah exactly
then you when you came home wrote two
very important papers but and I guess
you couldn't done that without the right
equipment and could you please tell us
something about this thing that was
another fortunate thing because it so
happened that in Brody's lab they were
developing an intern a new revolutionary
technique to measure in very low amount
by chemical assays rather than
previously only in my eyesight by
chemical assays you could precisely
identify and analyze a number of
important compounds some of them
endogenous such as da means we are
talking about others of course also
drugs and this instrument which was the
prototype I was working with on a
prototype but that later on became in my
eye a Minko this instrument company
constructed to be to become this
instrument that we see here and it
revolutionized the for example the an
analysis of endogenous compounds that
previously what could not have analysed
before but then by means of floor using
fluorescence rather than light
absorption you could gain remote two
orders of magnitude all of a sudden you
are down to concentrations that were
beyond reached before so this was a
fantastic instrument and the first thing
I did when I arrived back home was that
I ordered such an incident cause I
didn't have the money but I ordered it
that is that's a good way to get started
so I had to waste about the and I was
fortunate to be able to raise the money
there were amazing two papers and this
is one of them on the presence of
dopamine in brain could you first
comment upon this one and then we'll
come back to the resort beam in rabbits
paper later on yes yes this paper used
well for reasons that we will come back
to I became interested in dopamine
dopamine is another catecholamine but or
not on any interest to pharmacologist in
those days because it was considered to
be an inactive compound perhaps and
probably a precursor to the synthesis of
adrenaline and noradrenaline and
adrenaline but otherwise not interesting
but for reasons that probably we will
come back to we developed a method to
analyze dopamine in the brain in in
tissues in general and in the brain and
found it's there and it's there in
amounts that are at the same level of
noradrenaline so what we actually said
at the even date is first in this first
description of our method and the
results a very short paper in science we
said in muon these levels that we have
it's not we must consider the
possibility that dopamine is not just a
precursor it is it is an agonist it is
alright that was the first was an
important paper for that point of view
certainly and now we will have some
evidence for that assumption and first
you have already mentioned research and
this is just to show the plant from
which resorbing is obtained from the
root of this robot via plant and of
course it was used first in India but
then in in Western countries for the
treatment of those psychosis and and
high blood pressure and you discussed
already
Brodus experiments with his compound
what you did in this experiment was the
first definite evidence for dopamine
transmitter wasn't it yes our simple
reasoning was that if a it's an
important possibly important compound if
it disappears it could be actually
leading to a deficiency something that
Pro didn't occur to Brody because he for
some reason he thought was the other way
around we cannot have to skip that but
we simply said okay here we had a con da
condition well we have a deficiency in
Nora dread only because da da devil was
with what we had analyzed in in the
brain and we found two to be reported so
what what could we do in order to test
the hypothesis that here we have a
deficiency of normal readily
well we couldn't give noradrenaline so
easily into the brain because there is a
bright blood-brain barrier so I did me
attend but there is a precursor a amino
acid and this precursor for that
precursor there is a transport mechanism
across the blood-brain barrier and
inside there is an enzyme that could
convert the amino acid into kindly no
order nothing that was what I was
thinking so okay so we gave we we had
this reserve in treated animals they
were you will suit see a picture of that
they were the one on top here you see
they are they have a very very severe
disturbance of movements
very little wakefulness you could put
them in places as we did with these two
rabbits and very simple of positions and
I remained there so they were very
severe blue toric disturbance and very
low awake for this
and then we inject it intravenously dopa
this precursor is amino acid precursor
into the rabbits and within 15 minutes
you have the same two rabbits now
they're up and running and had most
astonishing result you must have been
amazed when it happened yes rikku yeah
yes well yes we yeah we were actually
well it came home not quite as
astonishing because we started out with
mice we couldn't see of course I started
to move no doubt but in the rabbit we
had could see so much so well it was a
we were we were just as excited as the
rabbit and then you measure the
transmitters in the brains of these
animals yes and we were so disappointed
because in spite of this effect I was
still they lived in the brain so that's
why we asked ourselves because we we
could conclude from the data that we had
that it has to be a an a being that is
doing this and the one that immediately
came occurred to us was of course the
intermediate between dopa and
noradrenaline dopamine of course
and even though dopamine was so was
recognized as a very interesting
compound we thought we must develop a
method to measure it and and we saw that
science paper already and and also
described in that tape
is that not only that dopamine occurs in
the brain but also when we gave her is
whistling also there's a dopamine
disappears and we could easily see that
was a clear-cut connection between your
current the reappearance on dopamine in
the brain and the the behavioral
response so depreciation so obvious that
what we see here is dopamine an effect
of dopamine no doubt perfect and and
that of course paved the way later on to
the treatment of this disorder
Parkinson's disease did it occur to you
at once that this could have
implications for Parkinson's when you
saw these rabbits or was that just later
on I must confess at the time we did
that experiment with l-dopa we didn't
even know that
parkansas mystic Pakistan is like side
effect occurs after treatment we
deserted oh no you are you're running
through the slides very quickly I can
see sorry for this small problem we lost
the connection to the it suddenly came
into my computer's dead okay yeah thank
you so that's something we learned at
about the same time that reserpine one
of the most serious side effects of
research is a condition closely similar
to the disorder Parkinson's disease so
so that was one
important piece in the puzzle there also
we found out of these we found that that
dopamine when they analyzed the
distribution of dopamine within the
brain we found dopamine occurs is it
especially high concentrations in the
basal ganglia and there have been lots
of speculations that that maybe there is
something wrong in the basal ganglia in
Pakistan has something to do with rumen
nobody knew what it was but but so we
had different pieces of the puzzle so
therefore we proposed that a deficiency
if you produce a deficiency in in
dopamine that will lead to the fuel
syndrome of Parkinson's disease that was
repopulated and then came on here it's
showing yes this was a case that
happened but in the meantime in 1960
when we published our and also went to a
meeting in London and published and
reported our data that I have talked
about already the experts in the field
said no dopamine couldn't be okay but
this study by kana kibbutz helped at
least to see that I could be something
in a sum something important in this
because in what he what he found was
that if you analyze brains porters
Morton or Parkinson patients these
brains are depleted very seriously
depleted the dopamine so that helped and
then of course given your rabbits and
natural of logical treatment here would
be dope and shortly thereafter koteas
introduced a treatment that you were
wearing to testing dope by in Gothenburg
as well weren't you before courts yes
yeah well I I went to
ecology is a very famous neurosurgeon as
a matter of fact in learned and proposed
that we should collaborate on this
interesting new thing he was not at all
interested and of course who could think
in those days then a little chemical
such a small molecule could do it could
the deficiency in that could lead to
this very complex syndrome or pocketses
that was too far-fetched to it for
anybody to believe in ok yes ok we must
come on here because time goes and and
and and of course dopa became the first
line of treatment for Parkinson's
theories many decades later first line
of treatment parkson's disease so we
just like to briefly comment upon this
on/off problem and and how do you think
this could be being managed as you
regard it today yeah if you look at the
left picture that say that's the early
face after you stop and as we as we did
and we could see our cells of shortly
after kotse as we started out it was a
bird and found that when we give l-dopa
to Parkinson patients the whole
symptomatology improves dramatically and
and they have if if one is careful with
the side effects they could be managed
to have a relatively mild side effects
so this is the picture that you have on
the left if you look at the picture on
the right unfortunately after a number
of years were quite variable number of
years you get very serious fluctuations
in the motility with very very
disturbing involuntary movements so big
what the reason for this we don't
understand fully but
at least there is one thing that has
become rather clear nowadays recently is
that if one avoids these dramatic
fluctuations in the concentration of
dopa and dopamine in the body that each
dose is given is giving if I could do it
convert that into a more stable
administration such as the so-called duo
dopa one can avoid a lot of this problem
so that was important and and this is
where I feel the movie move feel is
moving now in that direction okay in a
very interesting way so we can probably
get rid of a lot of the problems of the
fluctuations and maybe it could even be
that you never expose the patient to
these sudden high concentrations if you
start with a continuous administration
beforehand you can have a better outcome
in the nose yes very mild even
administration you will have you will
have much better results than then
patients have nowadays okay so the dopa
story still evolving that's not now we
turn to another condition and that is
schizophrenia and psychosis and this is
of course in 1952 when they layered any
care accidentally demonstrated the
antipsychotic effect of chlorpromazine
after available really had had made
experiment with this drug the surgeon
lab will and and at this moment of
course no one knew the mechanism of
action of chlorpromazine as an
anti-psychotic shortly thereafter this
gentleman paul johnson developed another
antipsychotic drug that is hollow paid
on you know poly onsen of course oh yes
he was a extremely proficient person he
was an organic chemist
his father started a small company drug
company so I get a drug from a certain
company and he as a chemist he started
to synthesize an enormous number of very
interesting compounds and not only could
he do was he a good chemist he could
also develop a good v lab that could
test what kind of whatever kind of
actions these drugs had and not only
that he could also bring them to the
bedside and all this could happen if he
you know just in a few years he had he
was we're very well known in Belgium and
he could get drugs on the market in a
very short time and the perhaps the most
spectacular of his many spectacular
products was haloperidol zeldo which was
doing the same thing as chlorpromazine
but much more specifically and
powerfully so haloperidol has the later
become very important in the development
of antipsychotic drugs and as far as I
understood it people didn't realize that
since resorting decreases dopamine
levels may be promising and on a pedal
do the same and that was tested and it
didn't do the same and then you did this
experiment we are now that was reception
again we are now going to this famous
1963 paper and what did you do
differently here as compared to other
people yes it was a simple reasoning I
thought that this was dope Robinson did
not cause any depletion or any of these
a means that reserve it does
and yet it causes a symptomatology in
the animals and a therapeutic effect
that's very similar research or
promising a very similar very similar so
how could that be then so then I got the
idea that maybe there is a some feedback
mechanism involved so I had we had
already postulated that there could be
some receptors for these a means and
maybe what could happen is that when we
give we certain when we give law
promazine
rather getting a depletion we could be
get the opposite we could get a
stimulation and why why could I be
stimulation well that is to overcome a
blockade of receptors so that was the
idea and this actually happened but this
was before even the concept of receptors
in brain establish so it was a quite a
bold and and and brave the speculation
wasn't it yes yes people thought so
but I thought it was soundly recently
but others feel they were so amazed and
continued to them they made for many
years and they have been there has been
lots of historical discussions about how
this came about so but that was how we
thought of it to be right and it was
published in a fairly humble Journal and
modest journal and then it was not cited
for some years and then we was the
citation classic yes yes subsequently
yes that is something I actually in
those days this idea
of publishing in prestigious journals
was not it was not nobody thought like
that before so it I mean it so happened
that some of our papers couple of all
have been done in nature and one in
science not because we were aiming at
something prestigious it's just so
happen no more journals just like Amazon
if you had another German it was the
sound of time one might say hey we are
in fact running out of time so much we
will hurry up here for moment and and
this is just the kind of modern you you
grow up at at that time this is from the
from from from the 60 seventies when
your your vision of the synapse at that
time and do you still think this is
valid yes it's interesting that perhaps
we shouldn't since we are short of time
we should it go into the different
different processes that you have the
big circle in the middle here that is a
transaction of the Nordic terminal it
could be one storing dopamine or
noradrenaline or serotonin but in
principle you have the same thing you
have a precursor amino acid get again
you have enzymes that convert the
compound into the transmitter in
question you have storage granules yes
that stole the transmitter and then it
is released by the denominator get still
a big cell you have on the right and I
mean it's on that cell that you have a
receptor so here we have all this was
described in 1965 and I think one can
say we have no reason to change anything
perhaps two we can be more precise
because here we have
we have put in comt that should be
located in the target cell that's look
at the catechol a missile transfer but
that's nothing wrong did okay then I
would just like to mention that
subsequently of course he don't mean
blocking effect of the antipsychotics
was confirmed by Schneider for example
increasing in radio ligand-binding
studies and also Zen in pet studies in
humans by by far than others and and I
think we can skip this one you did in
fact support the dopamine hypothesis
files started with the dopamine
synthesis inhibitor when the clinical
studies conducted in and then of course
coming to the pathophysiology of
dopamine there are in fact studies today
indicating that that there is increased
dopamine release in schizophrenia this
is very and do you still think you think
that this is part of the pathophysiology
today of schizophrenia that we have too
much dopamine in the striatum
it's more complicated yeah we have we
have areas where there is an increased
release of dopamine as demonstrated here
in the basal in under certain conditions
in schizophrenia but in other parts of
perhaps in the cerebral cortex that
could this better fact be the opposite
so it's a very complicated situation
that we have dopamine is out is not
functioning well that's for sure that's
for sure but exactly how that it's more
complicated okay and then of course
dopamine is not working in isolation and
you have drawn up various networks
wherever there is for something
important role of glutamate
this is one such scheme yeah this is a
way of demonstrating the site where as
psychotropic drugs act
through which new transmitter they act
and we have an interaction between the
cerebral cortex and some subcortical
structures in the basal ganglia in the
brainstem and so forth and this is the
first kind on that Tim to put down the
scheme for this complex interaction
leading to his psychosis okay okay then
we would like to say something about the
mystery of clozapine what would be your
Casa penis everyone knows it's an
atypical antipsychotic without these max
of the traditional and Scottish drugs
motor side effects and some benefit also
from the perspective of efficacy had we
had what is your pet idea today
regarding the the typical profile of
clozapine it's it can be best
illustrated by means of our drug I was
he was 61 62 because I think it is doing
the same thing as OSU 61 62 although not
so well we will come back to that
because we have some such it's it it's
John the Baptist before Jesus okay we
will come back to that drag that similar
drag later on but first a few words a
few words about partial agonist because
here you have also made an important
contribution this is just to illustrate
the concept of partial agonist that you
have an agonist that blocks the effect
of an ordinance agonist but of course is
a milder activation than a full agonist
and and you thought that this might be a
way to treat schizophrenia why did you
did you think that yes we we thought
that a partial agonist that our initial
thinking a partial agonist is a mixed
agonist antagonist so in other words if
you have a condition such as
schizophrenia well there is too much
dopamine in certain places
really
if you give a partial agonist it should
displace dopamine and thereby causing a
decrease in to alleviate psychosis that
was the simple thinking we had to birth
in the beginning later on when the auto
receptors came in it became more
complicated but nevertheless we thought
it would would be worthwhile to do
clinical trials and we did that and and
they turned out to show that they did
show that during treatment with a
partial agonist to this with this one is
the partial agonist - Triple P we could
induce a we could get a clear-cut
alleviation all of the psychosis but it
did last if we if we have a number of
weeks it the we lost the effect is not a
symptom reduction in the psychosis yes
that lasted for yeah okay so but it was
this paid with wave four four four four
our papers on deck started out from our
concept and with our methodology and and
they came to era P plus all which became
successful yeah okay now you want to
take the concept of a milder interact
with dopamine one step further I've
understood this is this is not a
partially frag inist it's all it's a
worker it more complicates more
sophisticated mechanism action very
sophisticated and you need
it's a stabilizer of dopamine function
and it's we have it will be very brief
in just in how come
complicated it well first of all
behaviorally it's very very clear-cut
effect if you have animals
that you put from our convenient home
cage to put them into a small cage with
no interesting objectives what do the
poor animals do they they start to
explore variegated an exploratory
activation and that lasts for an hour or
so but after that they give up they have
explored everything there is nothing
more to be seen so if you have the
column to the far left that is animals
that have been just treated with placebo
and they are not moving if then you give
to these enemy in their individual or
indeed the individual cages increasing
doses you get a very clear-cut
activation so the animals start to to
move again and actually we know from it
that actually what it looks here it's a
biphasic curve with a certain maximum
but this is this is a very important
finding and that I what it actually
illustrates we can say already now is an
activation of the of dopamine neurons
they start to fire they have stopped
their activity after the exploratory
phase has gone they are lying down and
now with you with by means of this drug
you activate the dopamine neurons by
blocking out the receptors and you get
this activation so this is this is
perhaps the most important fire finding
that we have
it's that then on the other hand it's
not like a normal egg honest because a
normal agonist would do this but this is
not what a normal agonist would do no
because if if you have animals that you
place right into a wide interesting a
cage rein full of interesting objectives
from the very beginning they have a very
high exploratory activity and if now you
give increasing doses or drug problems
and stimulating they are the OP doing
the opposite so you can if you have low
activity animals they stimulate if you
have high activity animals they inhibit
this is a dopeman stabilizing consolute
lee
we shall hurry on to we will have time
for a few questions at the end but just
hurry on to the next slide and that is
we should not go into detail here but
these are different populations of
government synapses and and what do you
think your stabilizer works in this is
this is what is done here this is
suicide safe sex picture actually for
Pittsburgh what she has done
babies are in the logic techniques you
have some some symbols here that are d2
receptor symbols and they are blue in
color they degree agree these green
receptors can be located in different
places and have very different functions
so if you are in the synapse where the
synapse is red in the synaptic cleft you
have very high levels of the Duro
transmitter which is released from
from the dopaminergic nerve terminal
which is going in the diagonal through
the picture here it's released into the
synaptic cleft it's a very high level
and because over to the opposite side of
the target cell that is that is the
postsynaptic side site and what we think
is we I can argue it would take too much
time but but we think that the our drug
are stabilizing drugs and to some
exemplary success the clozapine as well
they are unable to block here okay they
are unable to block so therefore the
fundamental basic function of dopamine
is bad but but what our compound is
doing in other places is the here we
have the auto receptors that you have
just outside the synaptic cleft and you
have a number 2 indicating on some of
them there are Auto receptors on this
nerve terminal and if you block them
that will stimulate the new law so that
that's why our our the exhausted or that
we saw the order the the pool if the
animals that were just lying there had
given up and if now we broke the auto
receptors the the dopaminergic neuron
starts to be to become activated and
that is why the animals thought once
again to try to explore the place to if
with the hope of getting out again
so so that is a very important function
but also there are other the other
receptors that are located outside the
synapse there you have colors that are
blue very pale blue finally and those
receptors they are important also
because they are play up they are
adjusted to whatever concentration is
available there so you have a very
complex interaction of different
populations of receptors and we we
should be able we should think of there
is lot more to be said about this I mean
there is also the howdy one receptors
come in and also we have the cell bodies
at the end right those receptors there
it's a very complex pattern but the the
thing with our compound is that is doing
exactly the right thing and it's a
miracle drug for the first time we can
control dopamine in a in a way in
different in a variety of different
disorders and our clinical studies some
of them very advanced especially in the
fatigue which is fatigue this is exactly
demonstrating these activation that I'm
that we mentioned to these inactive
animals where we have very good very
controlled controlled studies showing an
effect but we have data also in a
variety of other diagnoses so this drug
has a great future okay I think this
would be thank you I think this would be
a suitable final slide so we have time
for at least one or two questions if we
have got any and I now press the
question well here we have a nice
question from high leg Galloway what is
your secret for success you are
obviously a very important part
incentive community so I was just
wondering what advice can you give us
attendees on how to be so successful
reported question I think the most
important thing is to to believe
strongly in yourself and to be to stick
to it stick it out even if your people
don't believe in you if you have an idea
you have to go on and try it and work
very hard
you shouldn't go on too long because
sometimes you are not on the right track
but when you feel you are on the right
track you have to go on you have to work
hard in practice to to get more more
clever in the throttle methodology and
so forth in order to sharpen your tools
you have always faced a lot of
opposition haven't you for your new yes
they used to say they used to say what
concen did ten years ago was okay but
what he's doing now is not so good but I
have been going on doing this over the
century over centuries a decade okay one
final question and that would be from
Dawn crew shank and it is can dopamine
change people's predictions about their
future emotional state bit complicated
well yeah well what I would like to go
into there to mention is a very
important concept plasticity what
dopamine can do dopamine is very
important to keep the plasticity of the
brain in
good shape and therefore the few a
future the long-term fate of an
individual depends very much on
plasticity and if you keep dopamine in a
good shape plasticity will be active go
on being active and you can go through
the phases of your life in a successful
way you can even prevent dementia and
that is also why I think that the total
blockade of the dopamine receptors may
not be that good because when you switch
off this info absolutely that is what we
should do is the opposite we should
really be very careful prescribing drugs
that acted in having him inhibitory
action even even if it's a mild
inhibitory action on dopamine one should
be very carefully to prescribe such
drugs especially in the elderly and
unfortunately a lot too too much is in
terms of prescription 490 dopaminergic
drugs is being done in the elderly okay
thank you very much sorry that's been a
pleasure as always and and you have any
final comment well the pleasure is
mutual that's my final comment thank you
very much
I have one more message from the
organizers here lab route and they would
like me to mention that this webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through September until September 2016
you will receive an email from lab
routes alerting you when the webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event okay thank you very much
goodbye